guess  where  i am i'm sitting in the bleachers that  have beautifully been designed by tom  and mel who we created the whole set  with  and this is for our very  first live studio audience  we carefully chose the fabric  the beautiful seating  the gorgeous up lighting  to match the other side of the set and  also have people have beautiful places  to sit because that's what everybody  deserves  and if you didn't think this was enough  because my mind is so blown right now i  can't even believe that this is a  reality  well we have a whole second set  i am so excited so if you would like to  come  and join us on our show you go to the  drewberrymore show.com to get your  tickets  and we cannot wait for you to be here  we did the show with no audience this is  going to be something we appreciate  we're going to include you we're going  to ingratiate you  and try to make this the best experience  a studio audience could ever have  so  get your tickets